et c'est reparti pour un tour le club
franciscain est de retour pour
représenter la martinique en coupe de
france avec amours ses joies et peu de
sérieux et tout ira pour le mieux
allez voir et en plus de ça vous avez
une tonne de supporters d'ailleurs vous
messieurs à domicile comme sur place
j'appelle nîmes de paix trois minutes de
très jeunes mais avant d'envisager la
victoire face au prochain adversaire
entraînement avec application s'il vous
plaît et si le chef qui le dit telenet
qui est plus tard condamnée
lève c'est pas sorcier ce soir ou jamais
six maintenant je le plante pour les
maigres quelque chose pour aller tout de
suite quelques impressions des deux
gardiens du club franciscain qui l'on
découvre des talents cachés cher
attaquant attention vous pourriez être
surpris en découvrant la feuille de
match
ça se passe bien
maintenant je sais c'est mal et de
condition tout de suite de la bête parce
qu'un bon match nous attend samedi donc
d'entrée on s'oblige à la des bonnes
conditions
des extraterrestres squat 5% des
habitants de terre le 7 le reste des
habitants sont les ingrédients qui se
passe bien on arrivait tout à l'heure et
là on attend de faire un petit
entraînement pour se dégourdir les
jambes pour le moment cet après midi je
pense qu'on aura un match amical
sinon allez merci de nous avoir suivis
nous vous donnons rendez vous dès demain
pour avoir des nouvelles fraîches du cf
ciao ami depuis j'ai la main beebeejaun
candu les bandes qui me permet de faire
de la région